codeine is dead I've seen this
prediction thrown around more and more
lately but will programmers really go
extinct anytime soon it's in my best
interest to shill for the learn to code
industry on this channel however looking
into 2023 there are some really bad
looking storm clouds on the horizon in
today's video we'll look at six messed
up trends that might kill programming
once and for all along with a few shreds
of Hope at the end before we get into it
I'd recommend you sign up for fireship
pro to learn how to code with a brand
new platform I built from scratch that
provides an addictive meme driven
experience and this might be your last
chance to support the channel before
coding dies forever the first Trend I
want to talk about is stalled technology
now normally I love making fun of
Facebook on this channel but things have
gotten so bad with the metaverse that I
honestly just feel sad at this point
like the entire metaverse likely has
fewer daily active users than that
shitty side project that you totally
forgot about
foreign
like they just keep pouring money into
this thing and so far it's been nothing
but an embarrassing flop I'd highly
recommend watching this video from
mental Outlaw to learn more about why it
sucks so bad now even though the
metaverse sucks right now that doesn't
mean it's not going to be a big thing in
the future there are quite a few
Technologies out there that haven't
fully matured to the point where there's
a massive demand for new programmers in
the field but have the potential to be
huge in the future like self-driving
Cars 3D printing Quantum Computing and
augmented reality and these Technologies
are great but they haven't reached their
full potential like the smartphone has
and the big question is will they ever
get there in my opinion the adoption of
these Technologies has been pretty
disappointing so far if they never fully
mature that could mean a lot of dead
programming jobs the next Trend which is
affecting literally every human being on
the planet is the current economic
meltdown economists have no idea how
this rampant inflation could have
possibly happened it definitely has
nothing to do with all that money that
was printed the last 10 years to be fair
though even Nobel prize winning
economists aren't very good at making
predictions like in 1998 when Paul
Krugman thought the internet would have
no bigger impact than a fax machine now
that out of control inflation is a
reality central banks are raising
interest rates and that's a big problem
for programmers the vast majority of
startups and many publicly traded
companies don't make any money they
operate in the red and rely on investors
to bankroll their losses until they
become profitable or get acquired or go
out of business higher interest rates
make it much harder for Venture
capitalists to provide easy money for
these startups and that means startups
that do raise money have to be far more
careful about how they spend it and one
of the biggest expenses for a startup is
hiring programmers as of today the job
market still appears to be very strong
on a macro level however just last week
there were layoffs at Microsoft the
stock price of snap collapsed which
means they'll probably have more layoffs
then you've got Elon talking about
firing 75 percent of Twitter staff and
essentially all of the big Tech
corporations have started to slow hiring
and that's unlikely to change while
their stock price is tank as well and
even the FED said that unemployment
needs to go higher and you should never
fight the FED they're the house that
controls our Casino economy and speaking
of casinos another problematic trend is
the crypto winter Bitcoin is down 70
from its high of last year that's not a
great look for an inflation hedge and
there's been a variety of disasters that
nobody could have ever possibly seen
coming in a million years like the
collapse of Luna Celsius and Voyager
about a year ago web 3 or the
decentralized web was trending into the
stratosphere teenagers were making
millions of dollars trading pictures of
monkeys and it looked like web 3 was
going to make everything else obsolete
by this time this year but unfortunately
that didn't happen and now you don't
really hear about web 3 anymore whether
you like crypto or not it's decline in
popularity for the time being is not a
great sign for programming in general
these smart contracts require smart
programmers but if smart people aren't
using them then we've got a problem here
in my opinion I think web3 is in the
trough of disillusionment but will
continue to improve and grow in the
future an even bigger threat to the
lives of programmers is Mo code no Code
and low code
and we're molos though we're almost so
bro programming has kind of evolved into
a blue collar profession it's like being
a janitor but with less exercise luckily
as of today it still pays extremely well
that's why boot camps like Bloom
Institute of Technology formerly Lambda
school can offer a job guarantee of
fifty thousand dollars a year that's
nearly five thousand dollars more than
you would make at McDonald's working for
twenty two dollars an hour although they
also offer a free mcbus pass the reality
though is that technology is now
replacing many of the lines of code that
used to be produced by humans typing
into a keyboard there are tons and tons
of tools now that make it possible for
non-engineers to create basic
applications websites and even back-end
utilities and databases on top of that
Engineers are now writing code with
tools like GitHub copilot which move us
closer and closer to obsolescence there
are no doubt ambitious people out there
are foaming at the mouth with the idea
of entirely automating your job with AI
the technology is not there yet but just
look at how far it's come in the last
year we now have things like stable
diffusion and Dolly and voice cloning
that's indistinguishable from the real
thing it's only a matter of time and
when that day comes it's over
we are screwed
next up we need to talk about social
Media consolidation a trend that's been
going on for many years now Tech lead
made a video about this last week and
you can always trust him to tell you the
things that you don't want to hear in
that you think the ability to code is
like magic it's not we're not Wizards
nowadays the vast majority of content
creation has been absorbed by platforms
like Tick Tock Twitter and YouTube that
use the follower model for social media
why is that well it incentivizes
creators with money and internet Fame at
a time when the common person's
attention span is lower than ever like
more than 50 of Americans have not read
a book in the last year this is a
problem for developers because people
are no longer downloading apps from the
App Store every day or randomly surfing
the internet to find new content this
makes it extremely difficult to build a
new web or mobile app and make a ton of
money with it unless you have a massive
marketing budget behind it like when oil
first became a thing there were all
kinds of Prospectors becoming overnight
millionaires but nowadays you have a
small handful of companies that control
the entire world it's a bad trend for
independent developers because it's much
harder to take your side hustle to the
moon now the final Trend which has also
been going on for years is the cloud you
have big cloud platforms like AWS that
have been aggressively simplifying
basically all areas of development and
until recently that's mainly met fewer
jobs for system administrators and it
guys but now there are many tools coming
out that eliminate both front end and
back-end jobs like honeycode which is a
no code tool for building web and mobile
apps or amplify an entire back end as a
service in addition you've got a bunch
of new startups coming out with next-gen
serverless databases that further
simplify the role of a back-end
developer in other words as new
cloud-based tools make development
easier there's just less code to write
now this video may sound very
pessimistic but I think there is hope
you could always get into farming that's
what Bill Gates did after he got sick of
coding in c-sharp and now he's the
biggest Farmland owner in the United
States another Ray of Hope for
Millennials is that gen Z seems to be
pretty Tech illiterate primarily because
that generation is growing up at a time
when social media and technology is
already very Consolidated like I bet
many kids these days don't even know how
URLs work or that you can even edit them
in the browser and that's good news for
old Millennial developers who understand
these esoteric Technologies another
piece of good news is that it looks like
World War III could start any day now
instead of being drafted to the front
lines a good programmer will likely be
assigned to updating software on drones
and missiles while a good web developer
can update CSS on propaganda websites
now if that doesn't pan out I have a lot
of faith in the JavaScript ecosystem to
create an endless supply of jobs by
creating an endless supply of new
game-changing Frameworks if the new
Frameworks can always stay one step
ahead of the no code tools in the AI
then I think our jobs will be safe
another point when it comes to no Code
and low code is that this stuff has been
around forever like Microsoft Excel is a
low code tool in my experience it's
always been a dead end hype train even
if no code did hypothetically make all
Engineers obsolete you would still need
someone to code and maintain all those
no code tools ultimately when I take a
step back and look at the big picture I
see this massively complex ecosystem of
code and Technology that'll be
impossible to maintain and push forward
without a massive Army of skilled
programmers coding will never be an easy
skill and many real world systems are so
over engineered that they'll always need
highly specialized and highly paid
Engineers to work on that and just like
our banking system still needs Cobalt
developers the reality is that code is
just the most efficient way for humans
to develop software there will always be
ups and downs in terms of opportunity
for coders because of the economy and
whatnot however it seems highly unlikely
that the underlying skill set of writing
code can actually be replaced by
anything in the near future alright
that's enough talking I need to get back
to writing some code with GitHub
co-pilot thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one